but i i feel like another thing is that
i don't know maybe it's just me but
i think i just enjoy food too much all
right what's the problem yeah that's
that's the problem
it's it's not like i enjoy eating a lot
of food right but we talked about it
i do yeah i mean we talked about
enjoying the little things in life
every now and again and for me like my
day
is like 70 percent worse if i know i
don't have a good meal to look forward
to
this is why i've just become an ubereat
slave at this point like i
every day i order from it now that's the
problem it's terrible it's like but
especially because like japan
is just you know the land of [ __ ]
great food everywhere like food's become
a hobby
at this point yeah yeah oh it is just
like if i don't have a good meal yeah
that's like
i feel not i feel like i i feel i feel
like my day is just like yeah completely
empty i
i feel unfulfilled yeah i go to sleep
and i'm just like i'm i'm sad i have
nightmares
i i had the worst ubereats order of my
life the other day it was
it was oh it was [ __ ] tragic it was
like the pictures looked amazing the
ratings were good
you know and i was a pork ball booted on
okay and it looked very nice you know
and there was oh this place only did
pork balls i thought great they're
they specialize in this one thing yeah
it's going to be [ __ ]
magical so i order it you know it takes
a little while not like crazy
man and until it gets here and you know
it's packaged amazingly it looks like
you know they've really cared about like
the packaging you know
give you an uh or she bought it what's
your body yeah you know right now
like an actual like like oh like a
proper one like the rolled up one yeah
like real thick ones and i was like
i was getting really excited for this
i'm like hell yeah okay they give their
own chopsticks or really nice chopsticks
as well
okay so i'm like i open this bad boy up
it looks pretty good looks pretty good
and i'm like okay
fantastic so i dig in and i'm like oh no
and i'm like okay this is this
this part of the rice is kind of hard i
was like all right well maybe you know
maybe just this one section happens that
it clumps up right
and so i hit another part and i'm like
oh no this part's hard too
and then i put it in another part and
it's hard and i go
and then maybe maybe she needs a little
force maybe needs a little yeah i should
pull it apart a little bit
and i pick this i pick this up with like
the whole bowl
and i and i i go to just pick what i
think is a small amount of rice
and the whole rice comes out i picked
the ball up the whole ball
like formed comes out yeah and i i no
joke this is where i
started getting a little angry i started
like i had my chopsticks like this in my
hand like a barbarian
stabbing it and like ripping it apart
and i couldn't rip it apart
so i shovel the meat on top to one side
and this is where i just get i was like
barbarian
i literally tried to grab it with my
hands to see if i could separate this
rice
i could not separate this rice with like
my full grits wasn't like not even
cooked or what i don't know what the
[ __ ] they did to it and i i i gave them
one stars and i was like literally
don't give me a break next time and uh
they said sorry the literal brick of
carbs
they were like sorry you didn't like it
we'll improve next time give me a refund
i couldn't eat it i didn't get a [ __ ]
refund
and it ruined my whole night because it
was like 9 p.m and everyone closed
well i can't order anything down i'm
just gonna [ __ ] eat assembly or
something you gotta resort to [ __ ]
convene store food yeah i had a sandwich
so
i say having a meal to look forward to i
don't even mean like a [ __ ]
five-star gourmet just like a good
filling meal like just not even like a
knife just something on a plate you know
yeah
a decent thing on a plate i tear up you
know when i order a meal here and it's
just yeah